as we saw in the last several videos the
Roman Republic that was established in
509 BCE it finally met its end with the
rule of Julius Caesar we talk about
Julius Caesar crossing the Rubicon
becoming dictator for life and then he
is assassinated because of the power he
was able to accumulate in 44 BCE on
March 15 the Ides of March that throws
Rome into a civil war eventually it
becomes a battle between Augustus or at
the time Octavian vs Mark Antony and
Cleopatra Octavian is able to be
victorious and on 27 BCE he is declared
or this is the date that historians
often use is the beginning of him
officially being Emperor and this period
from 27 BCE with Augustus being Emperor
all the way to 180 C so this roughly 200
year period this is a relatively good
time for the Roman Empire as we will see
there is still a lot of conflict there's
still a lot of bloodshed but it is a
relatively stable period and so it is
often referred to as Pax Romana or the
Roman peace and who what we see picture
here these are most of the Emperor's of
that roughly 200 year period Augustus
proves to be a relatively good
administrator he lays a good foundation
for the next several hundred years of
the Empire the Roman Empire officially
being ruled by an emperor it's
eventually going to meet his demise of
the Western Empire at least in 476 C II
so it's going to go for roughly 500
years and Augustus lays a strong
foundation for it he's viewed as a
strong administrator he really builds a
lot of institutions from a historical
perspective it's it's worth noting that
Jesus was born under Augustus his rule
and most historical views are Jesus was
born in some place between four BCE and
BCE now augustus was followed by
Tiberius and Tiberius here was both
Augustus 'iz stepson and he married a
Gustus his daughter so he was a stepson
and son-in-law and he also proved to be
a relatively capable Emperor you can see
Augustus had a fairly long rule he took
power in his 30s and he his power ended
in his 70s and Tiberius too had a fairly
long rule from a historical point of
view or even a biblical point of view
it's worth noting that Jesus would have
been crucified under Tiberius his rule
the roman emperor referred to in the new
testament is Tiberius it would have been
his governor Pontius Pilate who orders
the crucifixion of Jesus now after
Tiberius you have his great nephews and
so you are his great-great nephew you
can see they're all not directly related
but they're all kind of family and his
great-great nephew is Caligula and
Caligula that's his nickname is a bit of
an infamous figure one of the infamous
figures in history amongst the Roman
Emperor emperors because he's really
viewed as a sadist as a pervert he's
known to for killing people just for fun
and he is quickly assassinated his term
only or his power only lasts for several
years and then in his place is put his
uncle Claudius after Claudius comes
another infamous figure of history and
that is Nero Nero
he's known for the route of Phi Rome had
a significant fire in 64 AD many of the
Roman citizens believed that Nero did it
intentionally to clear out space for a
palace significant number of Romans died
in that fire he killed a ton of people
including his mother he's maybe most
famous for persecuting Christians there
are some accounts that he would dip them
in oil and set them on fire in his
garden and it just as a source of light
so these people you notice to say that
they were insane or demented or sick you
know normally I try to avoid making any
judgment on some of these historical
figures but both Caligula and Nero if we
we believe the accounts that we get from
that period and that shortly after that
period were not by any stretch of the
imagination good people
Nero eventually does commit suicide and
with the with Nero's end you actually
have the end of the Giulio Claudian
dynasty write that down
Giulio Giulio Claudian Claudian dynasty
and the reason why it's called the
Giulio Claudio dynasty is that all of
these characters so let me let me circle
or more underlined them so all all of me
all of these characters right over here
are essentially from the same family
that are their descendant from both the
Julian line Julius Caesar and the
Claudian family so that's why it's
called the Giulio Claudian dynasty now
at the end of the Giulio Claudian
dynasty you have a new dynasty of
estación there's a short Civil War so
the Pax Romana is not without some war
and bloodshed in fact this whole time
there's a lot of relatives being killed
people who might threaten the emperor
being killed and that's just talking
about the Romans themselves they're
constantly fighting the dramatic tribes
and trend groups in the Middle East and
taking more and more and more territory
these extremely bloody thing they're
constantly enslaving people the Roman
Empire sometimes and these looks like
this neat clean idealistic thing but
there was a lot of enslaving of people
destroying of towns killing people out
of paranoia or really just out of the
joy of killing if you take the case of
Caligula or Nero so that you have the
Flavian dynasty I don't have the three
Flavian Emperor's depicted right over
here you have this you have this basin
you have Titus and you have the mission
of note the Colosseum the famous calcium
in Rome was built during their time
they're also known for the destruction
of the Second Temple in Jerusalem and
then after that you have what historians
and especially niccolò machiavelli so
this is many centuries later called the
good emperors and the good emperors are
these characters let me
let me square them off right over here
and these are really the last five
emperors of the Pax Romana and we should
even use the term good maybe in
quotation marks because for Rome's
enemies for the slaves of Rome for the
for the the people who were thrown into
the Colosseum just because they were a
prisoner of war or they committed some
simple crime the Roman Empire
didn't seem good but the reason why they
reviewed good is they were viewed as
able administrators they continued to
expand the Roman Empire Trajan in
particulars the peak of the Roman Empire
comes in terms of geography comes under
Trajan's rule that's this map right over
here this is the largest geographic
extent that the Roman Empire takes on
Trajan is succeeded by Hadrian most
known for Hadrian's Wall here the upper
bound of the Roman Empire and then the
Pax Romana ends with Marcus Aurelius who
is viewed as a he's actually wrote
meditations he's a philosopher Emperor
he's a face he's viewed as one of the
last great stoic philosophers and so
with that you have the end of this
period of Pax Romana and as we'll see in
the next few videos we then start really
getting into the decline of at least the
Western Roman Empire's will see the
Eastern Roman Empire outlives the west
by a good thousand years